joining me today is the founding editor
of Colette Claire Lehman welcome to the
Rubin report thanks Dave thanks for
having me I am thrilled to finally have
you here this has been like what 87
years in the making
yeah well I leave a very long way away
so it's difficult for me to get here
yeah well you made it you made it
thousands of miles you are part of what
I would say is IDW Australia oh yeah the
Diaspora
yeah exactly okay so there's a ton I
want to talk to you bout obviously I
want to focus on Colette and the work
that you're doing and we obviously have
a lot in common on the issues that we
care about and things of that nature but
first off you are from Australia I've
only had I think two other guests that
are Australian natives on the show yeah
what's going on in Australia these days
what does the rest of the world need to
know about Australia I would say that in
Australia we're pretty chilled out at
the moment at least politically and
culturally compared to America and even
Europe to a large extent we have a we've
had 25 years or more of economic growth
so people are pretty relaxed people are
doing well the middle class is doing
well there's not so much of a feeling
that there's a zero-sum competition
going on like people are fighting over
scarce resources and you know we
obviously have political correctness and
identity politics a lot of that's being
imported from America yeah how does that
get imported because I was mentioning to
you right before we started that a
disproportionate amount of our patrons
the people who support this show are
Australian even if things are going
pretty well there's definitely a segment
of people that are going something's
either not right or or we're seeing the
signs that something yeah it's true I
mean it's difficult to identify exactly
how these cultural trends get imported
but for example through universities
through social media through traditional
media so similar narratives get picked
up by journalists like the oppression
narratives and and we're seeing with the
with the young younger generations how
their
how they pick up ideology through social
media and through the echo chambers and
the filter bubbles that are so easily
accessible yeah yeah do you think that
there's a geographic reason that some of
this stuff hasn't fully hit Australia
yet I mean being surrounded by water
very far off place from the rest of us
there's probably a little bit of safety
in that I would imagine although borders
are changing just because of Technology
yeah it's um yes so we're more isolated
that's for sure we're smaller so we
don't have the same we're not as diverse
as other places like Europe and the
United States we have less income
inequality in Australia which makes a
difference and where we're actually kind
of Pro cool as well I mean we do pick up
cultural trends from America but at the
same time we just focus on cooking shows
and reality TV football games yeah yeah
so when the article came out back in was
it may or so the the Renegades of the
intellectual dark web you you were
included in there and many of us had not
even met you
yeah this is actually our first time
being in person yeah even though we
we've been chatting online for a while
were you shocked about the reaction to
that article because it really did sort
of level up all of the issues that we've
been all talking about no I wasn't
shocked at all I think that the general
movement this ideas movement and this
pushback of the the sort of moral
orthodoxy that the politically correct
left have at the moment it's been
brewing for some time and someone just
had to put a label on it someone just
had to name it and I wasn't shocked by
the groundswell of reaction to it
because I've been seeing it through my
work with Colette there are just so many
people who write to me every day who say
I love what you're doing I can't write a
blog myself account put my name on it
because I would get in trouble at work
or in my university but there are so
many P
or who want to participate in these
discussions but can't for whatever
reason and you know they liked it to be
now be able to put a label on this
general movement yeah so tell me a
little bit about your personal
background what led you to be one of the
people that is okay putting your name on
this stuff because I do think that's one
of the huge issues here yeah we get all
this support from academics even people
in politics and and regular folks who
are like yeah I'm with you and I see the
dangers but I don't want to put my name
on in this so how did claire lehman end
up here willing to put your name and
face to all this stuff you know i think
i have a bit more of a risk-taking
streak in my nature and i don't feel the
same fear around social disapproval as a
lot of other people so i was a
psychology graduate student and I left
my grad program and before I left I sort
of took a few risks during during my
program and was sort of hung out to dry
by the university so to speak yeah you
want to give me an example of one of
those you sort of lit up when you said
it well I I complained about the amount
of unpaid work that psychology students
had to do in a clinic that was
associated with the University and they
weren't happy with that and I sort of
received a bit of retaliation for sort
of almost whistleblowing on the amount
of exploitation this clinic wasn't
involved in so I I've always said the
first time I took a risk I've always
taken risks when I have felt that my
conscience demands that I I do so and
what led me to create Collette was when
I was a graduate student I was involved
in a lot of online discussions with
academics in psychology and we had such
fascinating interesting discussions that
were completely unlike anything that you
would see in mainstream media and I
thought firstly there's a business
opportunity here if I can bring some of
these
sessions to a market and secondly you
know people need to know that there are
there is scientific evidence and some of
these topics and mainstream journalists
and neglecting to inform readers about
some of these issues or some of some of
this evidence yeah so I want to read the
mission statement from Colette because
it'sit's pretty freakin perfect Colette
is a platform for free thought we
respect
ideas even dangerous ones we also
believe that free expression and the
free exchange of ideas help human
societies flourish and progress Colette
aims to provide a platform for this
exchange everybody seems to be afraid of
dangerous ideas right now right I mean
that's why this little crew of people
are together for whatever our
differences are yeah I think that
there's a there's been a conflation
between giving a platform or exploring
ideas and endorsing ideas and they're
not the same thing so I will publish
stuff on Colette that I don't
necessarily agree with politically I
don't see the the fact of publishing and
in necessarily as an endorsement I also
am very clear that I'm going to make
mistakes as an editor Colette
we don't want to make mistakes about
accuracy and if were ever called out for
publishing something that's not
factually correct we will own up to that
mistake but you know we're living in a
time of intense ideological flux and to
work out where we're all going we need
to be able to talk about things freely
and we need to be able to make mistakes
and I think make being able to make
mistakes is a sign of a healthy
environment and it's a sign of you know
it's part of the creative process yeah
so the the the the warriors who want to
shut down debate who want to shut down
free speech and argue that giving a
platform for exploring dangerous ideas
is equivalent to endorsing
they're basically saying that you can't
make a mistake and that's that's really
scary because the only way we move
forward is to experiment test new ideas
see see what works and pick the best
ones out of the experimentation process
and move forward that way yeah so I want
to discuss some of the dangerous ideas
yeah or that you're platforming but it's
interesting that you said this thing
about you don't mind making mistakes
because I feel very much the same I will
sit down with all sorts of people I've
done it before people I agree with and
disagree with some people who I really
don't like what they're talking about
but I try to give everybody a fair shake
and what I'm noticing is there's a
tremendous amount of pushback just on
that that's what you're getting to like
the idea that a you can sit down with
someone and separate a human being from
their ideas but also that there's this
sort of secondary thing that I'm
noticing and I think you you get it too
just from the articles you guys put out
which is that if I don't ask the exact
question that someone wants me to ask or
I miss this or I word this this way but
just this this army that doesn't feel
that organic to me is ready to pounce
and I'm really trying to work through
that like I don't spend too much time
thinking about it but it is a conscious
thing like oh there's gonna be this
group of people that no matter what I do
and really what they're trying to do is
chill everybody out so that you'll only
talk about what they're comfortable with
yeah well there are there are people at
the moment who feel that all of the
important questions have been answered
all of the important moral and ethical
dilemmas have an answer and that at this
point in history
everything's been worked out and anyone
who's exploring different ideas or is
doubtful about these moral issues is
evil your party argue you're racist yeah
yes so I come I come from a different
approach where like I don't know what's
going on like I I'm trying to work it
out with other people and I want the
freedom to be able to explore in a weird
way does that get you the most hate
because I think I really believe that's
where most people are I think that's why
people
and what I do here I'm just being open
about my journey and listening to people
and learning yeah yeah you know and that
but that opens you up from hate from the
both sides it's a lot easier to just
stake out a position and then you only
get hate one way but when you're like I
am gonna hear both sides you know it's
why I love listening to to Sam Harris
and George Henderson to ban you know the
biggest existential questions that there
are it's like yeah it's like if I've
completely settled my mind on this I
don't know I wouldn't be that impressed
yeah my thought process or something
yeah well you know I don't get a lot of
hate um I certainly have Twitter trolls
but well I wait till we I sort of don't
really notice it yeah okay yeah that's
probably the most simple way to deal
with this all right so let's talk about
some of those dangerous ideas what are
some dangerous ideas that have bubbled
up from your writers that you've had to
think about or that you're you're
focused on these days yeah so because my
background is in psychology we tackle
issues that come from the behavioral
sciences so we've looked at sex
differences psychological sex
differences between men and women
differences in interests in occupations
so we've published some articles on why
there are fewer women in computer
science for example and we published a
analysis of James d'amours Google memo
written by four different scientists who
have some expertise in that area we've
published on intelligence research what
were some of the results yeah well they
you know they basically said that
something pretty similar that he was in
the ballpark in terms of getting the
science right and his position is valid
in terms of regular scientific debate
there are observable sex differences
between men and women the differences in
interest in occupations is very robust
and reliable so women are overwhelmingly
interested in
occupations which have something to do
with people so caring professions
medicine even law whereas men have more
interest in occupations that are to do
with systems and things so anything
mechanical computer science and there's
no there's no difference between the
average intelligent scores between men
and women and the evidence around
differences in verbal and mathematical
ability is somewhat mixed I mean you can
you can have debates backwards and
forwards over the strengths of those
differences but the difference in
interest is very robust so why are
people so afraid of that why is it that
there is a set of people out there right
now that want us to act to be all equal
in their minds but it yeah actually
force us to go against nature I mean
that's what yeah that's what this really
is well there is a fear that if you
acknowledge that there are differences
between individuals or groups that
you're saying that one group is inferior
so there's been a like the idea that we
have to be the same to be equal has been
a very prevalent and strong idea I don't
know who came where the idea comes from
but it's it's um it's dangerous because
if you if you argue that no true
equality can be achieved unless we're
all the same then no true then we can't
have equality so however if you argue
that no we are all morally equal and
that we deserve equal opportunity and
the equal we deserve equal opportunities
to live a happy flourishing life however
there are differences between us yeah
and you can preserve that ethical
principle so it's very problematic for
people who think that there can be no
equality between men and women unless
we're proven to be the same
tentacle because the evidence doesn't
support the idea that way the same yeah
what are what are some of the other
dangerous ideas okay so we've probably
we're doing the dangerous roll yeah yeah
we've published work on intelligence
research which is controversial we've
published articles about the hairy
intelligence are you talking about
intelligence and race this seems to be
one that people seem to be all that's
yeah that's a hugely controversial issue
and we've published we published a
defense of the Charles Maurice the bell
curve because after he had his
conversation with Sam Harris Vox came
out and wrote a hit piece or wrote some
some kind of article that misrepresented
what they talked about and the bell
curve and so we published a response
from Professor Richard hire who's the
editor of the intelligence journal so
he's a preeminent expert in this area
and he defended Charles Murray's book
and defended the conversation that they
had and said this is an important issue
it's scientifically valid and has merit
to talk about these issues and they got
they work they got the science right so
we we don't aim to be provocative for
the sake of just being inflammatory
right we we have an objective where we
want to protect the scientists who have
who are doing this work or who are
having these comfortable conversations
we want to we want to protect the
individuals who are doing the knowledge
production or the research we want to
protect them from the boxes and the
journalists who just want to write hate
pieces just to get the clicks so we have
a sort of a commitment to those people
who are doing risky work and leave that
kind of protection you're going to my
soft spot today because as as we're
taking this only as we're taping there's
only like an hour
Vox did a piece about me about how I'm
part of the reactionary right yeah it's
just like you guys yes
so in a weird way your your job in some
respect has become sort of like a force
field to just allow people to do the
work yes that they're supposed to be
doing yeah that's right because
universities for all sorts of different
reasons are neglecting their duty to
academic freedom right and academic
freedom is meant to exist to protect
scientists in particular who are doing
work which contradicts the religious
orthodoxy of the time or the moral
orthodoxy and it's quite clear to me
that there are scientists doing work
which challenges politically correct
dogmas and I don't see universities
doing a very good job at protecting
those scientists and so we feel like we
can fill the gap where do you think the
the Gender Studies stuff fits into all
this because in a weird way it seems
like it's all being whittled down to
that somehow that now especially related
to trans issues I was just talking to a
fairly well-known public professor
yesterday off-the-record
yeah about how he's going into his old
even though he's factually correct that
it's calm you know confident about his
research he's going into old lesson
plans to change wording just because he
doesn't want to deal with the mob so
things that were completely acceptable
three four years ago yes now having to
edit out I mean that's that's truly
dangerous so what is going on with the
Gender Studies departments in the rest
of this ah it's all moving so fast it's
hard to really to analyze what's going
on when it's shifting so fast but
certainly many of the humanities
departments took a turn back in the
1970s and they took they took on these
fashionable theories such as post
structuralism and they they rejected
empirical methods and so when the
argument if we were trying to give them
all the credit yeah
that they're due at least in the
argument if you're if you're rejecting
empirical science or herbal facts what
is your argument that leads you there
because I know people are watching us
going that's just so it's crazy yeah but
they obviously believe it so let's try
to give the devil his due
yes so post modernists have a good point
and that is that we are all biased and a
scientist looking at an issue such as
sexuality has his or her own biases
right and so the questions that the
scientist asks when he or he or she is
designing a survey or designing a lab
experiment are going to have some bias
embedded within them but so that's true
and the post modernist had that insight
however the mistake they make is getting
rid of empirical and objective methods
all together and just saying because
we're biased what's the point right so
they're doing like a massive over
correction yes yes yeah when when what
should be done is acknowledging yes we
all have our bias and if I'm a scientist
designing a study I'm going to have my
bias and it might get embedded into the
work that I'm doing however there are
ways to correct that and we want to
improve our quantitative methodologies
in order to correct for our own biases
the the problem that the post modernists
have is that they say well the bias is
there so let's put it all in the bin and
we're just going to double down on the
bias and just talk about lived
experience I mean that is that's just
taking the completely the wrong
direction right I mean it's quite
literally the reverse of a scientific
yeah so basically they're they're saying
that that bias is truth right I mean if
you're saying bias that the lived
experience is what truth is then bias is
truth you know I don't know if you saw
it but I did this this talk at
University of New Hampshire and this
woman was yelling at me this trans woman
calling me all right and all of this
other nonsense shouting me down I didn't
realize this until two months later or
something but it turned out she was a
gender studies professor at school yeah
so you got a gender studies professor
trying to shout down an invited speaker
while live tweeting that I'm all right
or whatever yeah it's like I'm pretty
sure I'm not right about everything I'll
concede you on that even though I want I
said she should be treated with respect
yeah you know the quality and all that
but your bias that you're acting on
right now definitely is not closer to
truth yeah yes so I the way I think of
it is that you know there is an
objective reality and the way we get to
objective realities through the
scientific method whereas post modernist
academics believe a lot of them believe
that reality is created through language
and discourse and I think that's one of
the reasons why they believe that words
can be violence because if reality is
actually created through language and
discourse and there's some kind of
there's some toxic discourse then they
truly believe that reality can be
changed through words and so I think
that's why they get so upset about
freedom of speech and just having
discussions because they truly believe
that words can change the way the world
is constructed right so for now they say
it's okay to punch your Nazi well they
call everybody Nazis then it's okay to
punch a Nazi and then we can go
you know however far down that road we
want to go and then then you're
completely condoning but how concerned
are you that these ideas are going to
trickle up higher into places of power
and that once they look we know they're
in the media you've already mentioned
Vox and a couple of those other things
but that once they're really in the
places of power in Australia or in the
States or anywhere else that the screws
are really going to be turned against us
because yeah like for free speech
yeah I'm would be mostly be concerned
about these ideas getting into the law
traditionally the law is a conservative
field and they are pretty good at
resisting political fads but you can see
with the way that law is taught in law
schools at the moment that there is
critical legal studies and often
critical legal studies is a mandatory
component so they teach
like the feminist interpretation of law
and these approaches can undermine some
of the basic fundamentals or foundations
of how the law is meant to work so I
yeah I am worried that there are a lot
of attacks on Drupal due process at the
moment freedom of speech and the
scientific method those three things are
foundations of a civilized society and
all of them are being attacked at the
moment yeah how does me to fit into this
because you've been somewhat critical of
that I think it hits all three of those
out there look you know obviously me two
started as a really legitimate and
powerful movement in identifying that
the predation that Harvey Weinstein was
engaged in and and surely there are
there have been many powerful men in the
last couple of decades working in
industries where there's a lot of young
women around and they have positions of
power and they're able to exploit those
positions but you know I'm a young woman
myself right and I I don't see sexual
harassment as being as pervasive as a
lot of people claim and I also think
it's very dangerous to make accusations
against people publicly because our
reputations are so valuable and so
important that you know we need to
respect other people's ability to have
it have their their reputation and
making accusations in public sort of
goes against my my feeling that it feels
vindictive to me and it feels dangerous
a dangerous path to go down because for
every true accusation their years of
sexual harassment there's going to be
someone who is you know there's there
are going to be people who have
conflicts and then the conflict someone
feels like they can resolve a conflict
through making
an accusation of sexual harassment and
that's really scary we don't we don't
want people to resolve their conflicts
by making public accusations right but I
definitely think there's a certain set
of people that don't mind collateral
damage right I mean that seems to be
what's happening right now and people
you see this public people that are
tweeting these kind of things like it
doesn't matter if it's taking down a
couple innocent people that's how
dangerous this thing is that strikes me
as far more dangerous and I'm not
belittling any of the actual yeah things
that some of these women have gone
through yeah it's scary
it's the desire for collective
punishment and that collective
punishment is is scary it if you look at
the Geneva Convention that was
established after World War two the UN
declared collective punishment a war
crime so the idea is that when there is
a conflict between ethnic groups in
certain places if if one if some people
are killed in that inner conflict you
can't then go and wipe out a village as
a collection collective rich retribution
because that's how these war crimes
happen so now where this like you said
this collateral damage this desire for
collateral damage is being normalized
like people don't seem to understand how
dangerous this is and how unjust it is
but it is part of the issue that perhaps
they do understand it but they so want
to destroy the system this is you know
I'm I've been on tour with Jordan
Peterson one of the things he's been
talking about a lot lately is yes you
can acknowledge that we don't have
perfect systems and perfect systems are
probably impossible to ever get to but
now we have this new thing in the system
which is let's just freakin destroy the
whole thing to build our perfect system
yeah I I think people don't understand
because we're not taught anymore we're
not taught history properly we're not we
don't learn about human nature in school
and how it's almost an instinct to want
to desire retribution and vindictive
justice I think it's
it's part of our natures to want to
punish people and punish groups and our
institutions like due process and the
presumption of innocence they sort of
they go against our instincts but that's
why they're super weak yeah yeah yeah
and I think what we're seeing is just
sort of like a regression back to our
more tribal instinctive nature and
because that education system is so
atrophied young people aren't being
taught the value and the fragility of
these institutions how they came about
why they're so important why we must
protect them so that I think there's
just a basic ignorant about why these
institutions institutions exist in the
first place and then we're regressing
back to our more primitive natures yeah
how do you think social media fits into
this because I did a video I think it's
almost three years ago now that online
culture is becoming mainstream culture
and I think that that's what we're
seeing now what used to be just
relegated to the meme makers and the
eBay people has now just leaked
everywhere and just everyone in public
is acting sort of as their worst selves
all the time yeah it's all of this let's
either destroy the system or let's
ignore legitimate problems well when you
don't have proper law and order you do
get mob justice and vigilante justice in
real life and you can see that
throughout history you've got you get
lynchings you get pogroms you get groups
like mobs of people going in attacking
an individual who they think he's guilty
of like a sex crime or some other crime
and killing the person so and then what
happened was as we developed legal and
social norms that stopped that kind of
vigilante justice from taking place and
if you are a vigilante you can you can
get in trouble with the law and then
we've developed social norms that
prevent people from just forming mobs
and going attacking people in the street
but social media is this new technology
and we don't haven't developed any of
the legal or social norms yet and so
it's brought back this mobbing
havea which is part of our nature it's
brought it back but we haven't yet
developed any of the norms to sort of
suppress it or mitigate against it yeah
and I think we eventually will develop
these norms but it's going to take a
while and there's going to be a fitness
that people sort of metaphorically
lynched in the process yeah so that's
actually an interesting segue to
something that's been on my mind lately
so you know Alex Jones got booted from
Twitter and YouTube and Facebook or
whatever I don't even want to talk about
any of the things that he talks about it
does not matter mmm but but these tech
companies basically decided that this
one guy is too dangerous you know
Farrakhan can be on here and a mom yeah
remember you whoever else you want to
pick that you don't like and Beyond here
but this guy you know even PayPal took
him out last week do you think that the
free speech crew for getting his ideas
do you think we should have offered a
better defense of why this person but
person should be allowed to use these
things I mean should the guy be allowed
to make a phone call should he'll out
should he be like I've running water at
his house yeah where do we draw the
lines for this yeah well I think these
tools that we use such as payment
processing and social media such as
Twitter the instant messaging that the
tools and they should be treated as as
such like having electricity or water
and so you believe they're a public good
basically the same yeah what getting
water to your house getting the fall in
line connected to your house yeah and
and they shouldn't be politicized and as
soon as you politicize these tools then
it's there's a slippery slope and you
know then there's going to be arguments
about who do we ban next what standards
do we want to set and that kind of thing
in in the context of Alex Jones I think
there's probably more to the story that
the public is aware of so I don't want
to comment on him specifically but and I
don't want to make it it's just the
general idea that a digital
assassination can occur because we're
all agreeing to terms of services that
yeah I'm not sitting around with a
lawyer every time I click accept to the
news yes service yeah and that
eventually you could move on anybody you
know
and we know the way these ideas work you
don't get one person and then suddenly
be like oh well we're good to go
it's like who do you get next yeah and
the payment processing is is scary I
mean the idea that that should be
politicized is just that is crazy yeah
so what do you think the solution is I
mean I think you probably know my
solution is that we need more
competition but I'm really understanding
a big counter to that because it's like
where is the county where is it ya know
look I don't have the answer and I tend
towards being economically liberal
however some of these tools as you said
our public goods and perhaps need to be
thought of as public goods rather than
rather than private and you know I'm not
I'm open to ideas of regulation
government intervention and I'm also
open to ideas about breaking up some of
the monopolies because we competition
would be lovely but it's a bit difficult
at the moment because some of these
companies have got monopolies in lots of
different verticals so Google for
example has the search engine monopoly
they've got that almost got the
advertising monopoly so they're
leveraging their monopoly in one area
into others and that that just shuts
down competition yeah do you think it's
even something a little more perverse
than that which is that you know look
there's obviously I'm not blowing the
lid on anything here there's obviously
tons of discussions with all sorts of
people about how do we compete with
YouTube or how do we compete with any of
these things yeah but I think partly
what's happening it's not just people
are going there this this big monolith
other people are actually genuinely
afraid of what it means to go up against
them it's not like it's gonna just be a
hard work situation it's like what does
it actually mean to go up against the
world's information leaders well you
can't compete against the monopolies
that's the definition of a monopoly
there's no competition and and these
some of these companies are monopolies
and they have captured the market so
effectively that you cannot compete with
them and
so we either have to think about
regulating them so that they're free and
open to everybody or breaking up their
ability to control the market I mean
yeah yeah this is the tough part for the
libertarian part of me is like no no
idea yet I do sense I'm being pinned
into yeah that that kind of answer all
right so we've been talking a bit about
the tech component this grand cultural
war that's going on I you guys quill
that you're you're a small company or
you're funded on patreon which we're
funded on patreon it's pretty awesome
you have people that voluntarily pay you
to support your content yet you grow I
know how validating and rewarding it is
and all that stuff but you find yourself
often up against the big boys right like
that's funded to hundreds of millions of
dollars by different things and you're
being critical of them here yeah so it
does get me back to something that I
started with before about where does it
come from for you to just be brave I
don't want to I don't want to belittle
that part of it that there's a new
internet developing and I think it is
people that are doing this sort of thing
it's not these well-funded well-oiled
machines that were watching them crumble
you know I just you sent me this morning
this thing about boxes a drab is off by
15% or something and it's like we've got
slim trim companies and I think I really
believe that's the future economically
of this yep as well as in terms of
protecting the ideas yeah so we are
pretty we have a pretty amazing story we
I started by myself and I ran the
website for maybe a year or even a year
and a half before I got my assistant
editor on board who's now sort of the
managing editor and he's extraordinarily
talented extremely hard-working so I'm
very indebted to him for all that
Jonathan Jonathan hey and my other
editor jaimé okay jaimé more yeah okay
yeah let's give credit where credit yeah
yeah and um and my contributors are also
amazing but we are hit now as of 2020 18
September we're getting up to 1 million
unique visitors
a month with the staff of all part-time
staff of six or six or seven people and
we're getting almost a million uniques a
month I am aware of magazines that have
a budget of millions of dollars yeah
that cannot compete with our traffic and
who have staffs of stuff like staffing
capacity of 30 40 50 people so we're
extremely lean but we're hardworking
and we're nimble and innovative like I'm
very I'm always thinking about
innovations to the business model what
can we do that's different I think just
following in the footsteps of the old
model is probably a recipe for failure
and I truly believe that advertising is
on the way out I know people can still
make some money through advertising but
I think out of it advertising gives you
a vulnerability because now you see
these activists trying to like target
brands if their brand is next to some
content that activists don't like so I
think advertising is just I think it's
Vonn there's a vulnerability associated
with it and is it almost a fake
vulnerability though because I always
think when you know they always try to
boycott Hannity for example and it's
like all of the people trying to boycott
him and putting aside whatever he said
on that given instance they don't watch
him in the first place and yet the
advertisers still feel that they have to
bow to the mob and I always find that to
be a strange thing like there's very few
people who like Hannity who are so
shocked by something he said that they
want to boycott it it's always people
who hate him in the first place that
don't watch so there's an odd piece of
this that's like slightly disconnected
from reality I think well corporations
and companies in general are skittish
and conservative and they want to
protect their reputations and they've
they're afraid of any kind of
controversy and I agree with you that
these activists on social media who are
targeting companies they're a tiny tiny
minority of the population most people
don't care or buy into this stuff but
corporations is it's probably some PR
person who's like whoa we don't want any
controversy let's detach ourselves but
you know it that kind of timidity and
lack of strength and lack of spine it's
not something that he's part of Colette
so we very much conscious of if we ever
get mobbed and we do get mobbed
sometimes we don't apologize we don't we
don't we don't give in to the hecklers
veto basically yeah and I really think
it's important for corporations company
leaders anyone in a leaders leadership
position to grow a spine in the era of
social media and to not take any of this
outrage seriously yeah yeah not take it
seriously or not take it I mean I think
we've sort of we have to take it
seriously because it is sort of
infecting a lot of society but maybe not
take it as if it's necessarily right
just because it's outrage is that fair
yeah you can say the recent example an
editor of the New York Review of Books
in Barama was fired because he published
an article by a Canadian radio
journalist who was credibly accused of
many cases of sexual assault and I think
the radio journalist was like he's a bad
dude but the editor was sacked for
publishing his article within like the
space of two days or something so there
was a social media outrage phenomenon
and it's all wrapped up with me too and
then he's just fired just like that and
it's like okay take some time out to
consider it like listen to the feedback
from your readers or from people on
social media but when did we start
making decisions so suddenly these
important decisions that affect people's
livelihoods that's what I find
astonishing that people in leadership
positions just sort of throw all caution
to the wind and just say okay we're
going to SAP someone because some people
on Twitter unhappy yeah and also the
guilt by association part of this right
I mean it's it's possible for a slim
trim operation that you have you might
find out in ten years you might find out
that one of the guys you're working with
now three years ago did something awful
and then they'll use that to try to tar
you and yeah the danger in that or that
you sat down with somebody and now we
can put out a chart that links that
person to this person to that person
we're in an age of the internet within
six steps you can link anybody to Kevin
Bacon or Barack Obama insight it's
pretty ridiculous yeah look guilt by
association is manitto fallacy but it is
powerful and we we do find ourselves
tainted and it's tricky and I think we
have to every situation we have to judge
on a case-by-case basis and and you
probably right it probably is going to
happen but I I trust my readers and I
feel like they know who we are they know
they're aware of our values and they can
make the appropriate judgments at the
time yeah so alright so even though
we've spent most of the time here and
most of the things that you guys are
writing talking about what's sort of
going on with the modern left
yeah frustrations that everyone knows
that I have like these guys yeah let's
talk about the parts of the right that
that you actually find scary or untoward
or whatever you want to call it what do
you think the alt-right
is at this point like if someone says
you give me the definition of alright
what does that even mean to you at this
point well I consider them to be the
white nationalists that that one in if
ethno state and they're pretty morally
repugnant and they're pretty scary and
they're engaged in some in quite vicious
trolling they send death threats the
journalist Kathy young for example was
one of the first people to write an
article
Curtis
the bigotry of the Opera and she had
death threat called into her home
and they're pretty scary but I think
they're a small group yeah how are we
able to quantify that because that's one
of the things that like I think people
are just very confused that they're
making it seem the media makes it seem
because they call everyone alright or
far right yeah there's this massive
group I can only talk about this in an
American lens but maybe it's a little
difficult but that there's this massive
group a white nationalist who are coming
for to turn America into some sort of
ethno State now I'm not saying there
aren't racists of course there are
racists and of course there are bad
people and people using these tactics
but I believe it's just a tiny sliver
and then and then on top of that you
have all sort of the meme makers and the
[ __ ] posters and the rest yeah yeah
those guys you may not like what they do
but they're not there they're having fun
in their eyes and yeah is there not just
the evil racist yeah yeah yeah I think a
mistake was made back when Milo was
around and I think he he started using
the term all right and he might not have
been aware of where that term originated
and actually originated with the white
nationalists and so you think you think
Milo was using it more in the way that I
just laid it out or just sort of these
[ __ ] posting memes yeah yeah thing look
without acknowledging the other piece I
don't know if he was aware of where the
term originated or not but it was a huge
error error for people who are adjusting
to shitposting it was a huge area of
error for them to use that label for
themselves because unless you're a white
in my view unless you are a white
nationalist you're not on you not an
authorizer I mean they had they the
label I think came about in 2007 and
they I think it was Richard Spencer who
created the alt-right Journal or
something so it was a big mistake for
people who just want to have fun online
and who want to you know just like push
back against some of these PC
orthodoxies it was you
mistake for them to use the term for
themselves and that's given license now
for critics to apply the term on
everybody who pushes back against PC
dogmas and that's really unfortunate
yeah but you know we have to just say it
over and over again like these people
are repugnant and we don't want to have
anything to do with their ideology the
ideal is all ideologies authoritarian
it's racist it's some and and they
engage in very scary vicious behaviors
yeah so absolutely I will cosign all of
that yes for the record of course this
is a repugnant ideology and these people
are racist yeah things so I'm less
concerned about that because I do
believe it's a small sliver that doesn't
have real institutional power now maybe
that's going to gain some and I think
there's evidence that at least in
Eastern Europe but some of these ideas
partly is a push back to me immigration
problems that maybe it is gaining some
power but are you concerned that it has
a bigger institutional power because I
think the stuff that we're often talking
about is because we're worried about
institutional power yeah
and structural power not just that there
are mean and bad people out there which
yes there are mean a bad people out
there and there will always be mean and
bad people out there
yeah because my background is so
recently in academia I focused a lot on
universities and the ideologies that are
popular within university so that makes
me focus on left-wing ideologies such as
critical theory post structuralism and
and Marxism if I was in a different
context I might focus more on right-wing
ideologies and the effect that they have
on institutions and I'm sure so you're
giving a little nod to the post
modernist there because you're showing
that your own bias is a little part of
how you look at things yeah yeah
absolutely yeah
yeah I'm sure if I was closer to
institutions that have more of a
right-wing ideological influence I would
be criticizing that more
criticizing those influences more yeah
being Australian is in Australia our our
conservative or right-wing ideologies
are quite different to America so you
probably already know this but we have
universal healthcare
we have gun control we have a welfare
state so if I lived in a country where
we didn't have those things I would
probably be advocating for those right
but you know a lot of this is context
specific and you criticize what you know
so a part of the reason why I criticize
the what Jordan Peterson calls
postmodern near Marxism is because I've
experienced it I see it all of the time
enacted in academic settings and I worry
about the impact that that ideology is
having on media the law and just a
broader culture yeah are you hopeful
that some of the good ideas that we've
talked about here are going to win out
that seems to be one of the biggest
questions I get at public events now
like I think there is a sense that we've
woken up a certain amount of people you
know this Petersen Tours selling out
every theater thousands and thousands of
people really all over the world will be
in February in Australia in February
yeah um but I think there's still a
concern of like how much worse can it
get before it gets better
yeah and that's a question people ask me
as well and I the I mean I don't have an
Oracle I can't see the future and all I
can say is that I'm doing my very best
to counter these bad ideas and that it's
it's actually anybody who's concerned I
mean they have some responsibility and I
think everybody should think about
sharing the risk so you know when
Charlie these people truly yeah you know
when Charlie Hebdo happened and the
mainstream media in
Europe and the UK and America I think
didn't want to publish that cartoon of
Mohammed which got those men and women
killed Douglas Murray came out and said
Stuart share the risk that's when I came
where yeah that's one of his best
moments it's incredible it's on YouTube
yeah that was a something that impacted
me a lot as well and you know I
anyone who's concerned about the way our
culture broader Western culture is
headed needs to think deeply about how
they can make a little bit of difference
by sharing the risk just speaking
honestly in conversations with friends
speaking honestly and openly in the
workplace normalizing conversations and
yeah just just taking on a little bit of
risk yeah what does that tell you about
the slide that has occurred in the West
is this just a is it an infection of
success or something that we could be so
successful that even taking a little
risk seems awful to people humans are
very conformist and most people are
cowards unfortunately and a lot of what
we're talking about these bad ideas that
are being promoted only promoted by a
tiny tiny minority of people but they're
very noisy loud and aggressive and the
problem is simply the silent majority
not being feeling too intimidated to
sort of push back and if we can
encourage those who are in the silent
majority to push back against ideologues
on both sides both the hard right and
the hard left I think will create a much
healthier civil society yeah but it's
about empowering the moderates to speak
freely speak openly and and and not feel
afraid
like ashamed of their moderate views
right they've also turned words like
civility and moderation are thought of
as bad now you're a fence sitter you you
want to murder half the people you know
you're not Thanos from Avengers you was
beautiful yeah I mean the Larry's people
that people who argue that civilities is
a bad thing and we see a lot of this now
by the way that civility is a bad thing
a lot of think pieces about this well I
would argue that some unrepresentative
of the broader population I know that
media and certain parts of media and
universities have been captured by
cultists in a way and they have these
crazy ideas but I would be careful about
generalizing those ideas to the broader
population because I think most normal
people are pretty chill yeah I mean I've
been not enough time in your country to
- no no I think you are right I mean I'm
out there going across the country
realizing that there are so many just
decent yeah people yeah the hysterics
and the way that I said earlier about
how social media has leaked into reality
or something yeah it's making everyone
feel crazy but I am meeting these
incredible people all over the country
yeah they just want to live and let live
and yeah maybe I don't know your
feelings on abortion for example maybe
we agree maybe we don't it just seems
that actually seems irrelevant not a
moment yeah that sort of says something
we touched on briefly right before we
started that politics I was saying how
I'm not that interested in politics per
se at the moment even though this is all
framed within a political lens and I'm
much more interested in culture yeah is
that how you feel about this and was
that always how you felt about this or
has something shifted definitely I've
never been particularly interested in
partisan politics but I think that
politics is downstream of culture so the
ideas that are popular within a culture
then get reflected in your politics so
if you want politics to be a certain way
and to be a bit healthier and less
dysfunctional you want to impact the
culture first because culture is bigger
than politics yeah is there a danger
that we're just in this like locked
culture war now so that our politics can
never get better like
sort of have this authoritarian leftism
and now we've got Trump
these are the cultural fights that we're
having now there's a couple of us in
this spot right but like that if all
politics is going to come from those two
things at the moment that politics sort
of is almost irreparable damaged yeah
look I don't know what the future holds
for the United States from an outsider
looking in it it does look quite scary
the theory level of tribalism that's
that seems apparent just the and the
amount of hate and distrust that each
side has for the other it's quite scary
I just hope that if the worst happens to
the United States we will always have we
will have outposts where Western
civilization through survives and
thrives New Zealand Australia basically
going back to what I said at the
beginning it's good to be surrounded by
water yeah yeah we'll be we'll be an
outpost yeah yeah yeah we're gonna need
that much yeah yeah yeah a lot of people
are going to New Zealand and buying
houses there in case the worst happens
oh god I don't want to end on this
terrible over here wait we've got to
bring this back but all right so there's
concern about that
of course like right if you want to go
down that rabbit hole you can look at
all of these ideas that I truly think
are the ideas that could unravel Western
society and free thought and all those
things that's why I talk about them so
much yeah but there is a counter and
then that's what we got to keep doing so
bring could bring me home on a positive
note please before people start buying
real estate and museum or you were just
trying to help the market in Australia
there no no you don't need any help in
housing like it we I'm optimistic
because I see the amount the positive
reception that I get through Collette
our audience grows every month more and
more people are contributing to our
website feeling brave enough to write
their thoughts down and send it through
and the thing is every individual has
the power to change the world of ideas
if you
got an idea and you can articulate it
and write it down and send it in or
articulate it on in in some other
fashion you do have the power to
transform and impact this this culture
and to make a huge difference so that's
that's incredible and that makes me feel
happy and optimistic all right that is
how we can end it we can't end it on the
seasteading we're gonna make water world
kind of thing
for more on Claire's work check out
Qualcomm and they are also on patreon
[Music]